When movies as popular as the Back
to the Future trilogy come along,
fans always end up wanting more.
"You know that new sound you've been
looking for? Well, listen to this!"
And while it's been more than 30 years
since the release of the 1990 smash hit
Back to the Future Part III, beloved actor
Christopher Lloyd seems game to reprise his
iconic role of eccentric inventor
Doc Brown. In a 2015 interview to
celebrate the 30th anniversary of the first
film, Lloyd told The Hollywood Reporter:
"I would love to do Doc again, no question."
But wanting to do another movie is much easier
than actually making one. Of course, there's the
tremendous amount of time and resources that
go into any big budget Hollywood production.
But there's also the very real risk that things
might not turn out as well as the studio — or
the fans — might hope. Beyond all that, however,
there's one more major factor that will dictate
whether Lloyd would reprise his role for
a theoretical Back to the Future Part IV.
The Back to the Future trilogy tackles
many themes, not the least of which is
the relationship between Marty and
Doc Brown. It's a friendship that is
stronger than ever in real life too, and
without Michael J. Fox's participation,
Lloyd told The Hollywood Reporter that he
would put the kibosh on his return for Part IV.
"Great Scott!"
In fact, Lloyd said he would love to see all
the creatives behind the trilogy back for
another Future trip. Referring to Fox's
1991 Parkinson's diagnosis, Lloyd said:
"I think regardless of the Parkinson's, he'd
probably jump on the role, and he'd be great.
I can't see doing another sequel without
him. I would certainly want Bob Zemeckis
directing it, Bob Gale writing it and
the other principals being involved."
Of course, maybe it's no surprise that he'd
want Fox to join him on the next adventure,
considering how much they enjoy working
together. In an exclusive interview with Looper,
Lloyd looked back at his relationship with Fox.
"It's a thrill whenever we get together. He has
just such a loving, wonderful sense of himself
in his situation in time. Really, he just
has a perspective, and a sense of humor
about it, and a kind of joy.
He loves being who he is."
Lloyd also told The Hollywood
Reporter that they'd have to
bring back the trilogy's iconic
DeLorean, of which Lloyd said:
"It was such a perfect choice for the
film. It looked so speedy and futuristic."
One thing Lloyd doesn't
want to see happen, though,
is a full-blown reboot of the franchise. He said:
"It's hard to replace Marty. Michael
J. Fox was so wonderful in the role."
Sadly, even if the stars were to align
for another Back to the Future project,
other variables would have to fall into place
too. Most importantly, according to Lloyd,
the fourth movie's story would have to rival
that of the first three. One thing that can
certainly be said for the original trilogy is
that each movie had a genuinely original plot.
Back to the Future saw Marty forced to keep
the past on track after traveling back to 1955;
Part II found Marty and Doc having to
avert a terrible future; and Part III had
them both travel to the year 1885, in a total
shake-up of the franchise's sci-fi stylings.
They're great stories — and Lloyd is well
aware of this. He told The Hollywood Reporter:
"It's tough to come up with an idea
that contains the excitement of the
original three. [...] But it
could be done, you never know."
But while a new movie might not be on the cards
just yet, Back to the Future fans can at least
enjoy a trip down memory lane. In the spring
of 2021, Lloyd joined host Josh Gates in the
Discovery+ series Expedition: Back to the
Future. Over the course of four episodes,
Gates and Lloyd hit the road to locate the
original movie's A-car — the DeLorean that
was backed out of Doc Brown's moving truck at
the mall in the first film. The goal, after they
locate it, is to donate the car to the Michael
J. Fox Foundation for Parkinson's Research.
In his interview with Looper, Lloyd said that
he essentially reprised his role as Doc Brown
in the series, because, in real life, he and
the character are essentially one in the same.
"So, I wasn't doing a character, I was
being myself. Usually when I do [a role],
it involves taking on another life.
The one I'm taking on in this instance
is my own, and so it had some intricate
areas, in my head anyway, to explore."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.